one of the best ideas i have ever seen
on a talk show
was having your ex-husband on tom green
tom green i admired tom green i thought
he was a funny guy
so did you and you fell in love with him
but you guys hadn't spoken in 15 years
almost 18 years yeah tom was being very
nice and you were being very nice
the two of you were looking at each
other almost like you were still in love
but what happened there why are you and
tom not married
we just were young and we were you know
kind of idiots and and like
what were you idiots about why do you
say you were an idiot
26 i was so i didn't know
how to manage myself
i've always said i was a woman in the
boardroom and a child in the bedroom and
what i mean by that was i could
always handle my professional endeavors
i could go into a studio and
pitch why we were the right people but i
was like
i didn't know how to handle things in my
personal life
why had the two of you never talked i
think tom
needed some time i think it was hard and
i think his
coping mechanism was to build a little
bit of a wall
and i respected that but i reached out
to him over the years and he just
wouldn't return the calls
a little bit more initially and i just
got the clear message and so i backed
off
out of respect and then time goes by and
i sent him a video and i was like hi
it's been a long time and i was just
wondering i'm starting a new show
you know what that's all about because i
had been a fan since he was on cable
access in canada
let alone before he got to mtv and
i said you've launched a lot of shows so
you know exactly what
waters i'm in and i just thought
besides everything even if it never
happens this felt like the right time
and an excuse
to say hello check in and see if maybe
the timing is right and it just couldn't
have been sweeter
it was he's very different we're both
very different
and we met based on respect
and we've come full circle right back to
that respect
and that's where we're at